You know, fashion came up to me quite late.
And I never had the dream of being known through the world.
But being a woman, I really take the world of pret-a-porter,...
...ready-to-wear, literally.
And it's true that for me,...
...it's not about dressing a woman for a special occasion.
It's more about, "Okay, what do I wear this morning?"
It's easy to do a fancy dress that looks great...
...but then you look at it and say, "When am I going to wear that?"
The fashion world is looking for new things, amazing things,...
...things that they haven't seen yet.
And it's very difficult to combine a certain creativity...
...with keeping in your mind that it's a kind of art...
...but in the end, it's something that has a purpose.